excuse me ladies and gentlemen my name
is samaria johnson
i didn't really come out like when i
hear young people talking about i
gathered everybody in the liberals
excuse me i have something to say
do you think i'm an alcoholic um
if i only freeze my head is it like
cheaper it is cheaper it's a broke
people thing that only freeze your head
that's right
[Music]
could i like leave my car to my cat you
can
that's cool
my brother he got locked up he was 18.
he came out of jail a dude that loves
pepperoni six now and wearing his phone
on his belt he could feel just as
uncomfortable around you as you do
around him
as a gay person i do check if a place is
game friendly i don't want to be
overseas
breaking all the rules because i'm
holding my [ __ ] hand in the fight
whoa
if we present what we are which is messy
because people are messy all bets are
off dope
and if you show all of it you leave room
for everybody well i just like [ __ ]
and hanging out with my homies that's a
whole nother episode
i'm from boston bro i've been around the
whitest of whites
what's a wine expert called
sommeliers like i'm that of crackers
[Music]